all right welcome to the introduction to
JavaScript course at scrim be calm we're
gonna be talking about a lot of things a
lot of important concepts in JavaScript
starting with data types and control
flow and basically everything that
you're gonna need to get up and running
by the end of this course it's gonna be
covered over 14 lessons with seven
different challenges these challenges
are going to be some concepts that you
may know the answer to if you're paying
attention in the course or you may not
they're they are designed to introduce
you to some of the stranger or weirder
parts of JavaScript a little bit about
javascript javascript is written in ten
days it's an event-driven language and
object based language and it was
originally designed to make web pages
more dynamic that's where it has grown
and flourished although you can use
javascript for databases for the backend
for mobile applications java scripts
home is in the front end client-side
development with HTML and CSS it's one
of those core three things HTML is sort
of the body CSS is how it looks and
JavaScript is making sure that it's
dynamic a little bit about me I've been
working in JavaScript for about two and
a half three years as a I've been I'm
currently a front-end engineer although
I do full stack I'm also a content
creator on YouTube if you click on the
icon you can go check out my channel I
do software tutorials and talk about
topics related software as well as my
own udemy course I'm really excited to
be making this course let's go ahead and
jump right into it
so in any programming language you're
gonna need a way to store a language and
values and the way that we can do that
in JavaScript are with three main
keywords var which is essentially
deprecated and I don't recommend we use
so we're not going to cover that because
I don't even want that to be part of
your mind but if you see var you know
example equal to true for instance we
now can console.log example like so save
it it's kind of logging it out right so
if it's gonna print it out that's what
console.log does but here we're storing
a reference to the value true and if we
wanted to make this you know Dylan for
instance and we save just update it
you'll see it's gonna print out Dylan
right don't worry about var and so do
using var what you want to use is let
and when we get to for loops I'll go
into a little bit more detail as to why
devar has been deprecated but right now
when you're storing values that you're
gonna override in the way that we
override variables we already have
example defined here well you know I
didn't say example is now equal to we'll
do my last name Israel right is our ad
I'll save it it's here we're never we're
not getting done although Dylan is
originally set I think it's overwritten
by example here with our let now if we
wanted to make a constant we would use
cons but you see we get this syntax
error the reason for that is when you're
dealing with a constant when it when
you're talking about strings when you're
talking about boolean x' when you're
talking about numbers and we'll dive
into datatypes in the next video but
constants cannot be overwritten when
dealing with the primitive values and
we'll talk a little bit more about
primitive values in Dave College but
typically if you're gonna override
values like so or if we wanted to
override right here get rid of that
that's resetting the value we would use
a Const right but if we're gonna reset a
value potentially we're gonna use let
we're gonna dive a little bit more into
detail about how that is typically true
unless we're dealing with a
or objects in the next video we're going
to talk about data types but in terms of
storing data what you're going to be
using this letting kant's
all right let's start by talking about
what a string is you saw earlier we
printed out my name and with we're
putting out my name is in console.log
and we have this variable here called
name and so it's gonna go ahead and
print out Dylan right we showcased that
earlier so what this is called this
datatype here is a string we can
actually use this type of word here one
word to actually find out what it is if
we want to print it out and you'll see
that it's printing out string so that's
one way if you ever get confusing and
kind of check that out right there's not
too many data types in JavaScript which
is nice but you'll see here we have
double quotes around it we can also do
single quotes but the the quotes have to
match right we can't have a double quote
on one side and a single quote on the
other and that will work as well so one
other thing let's let's actually go
ahead and make this first name and let's
create another variable called last name
and like I said this Israel and notice
how I'm ending these statements with
semicolons as well this is a good
convention so what we'd want to do say
we wanted to concatenate this well we
could do something very very strong will
you do something like this where we do
first name plus then we want a space
write an empty character plus last name
and we save it and then we're gonna get
this nice spaced out we're here well and
you'll notice we'll showcase it without
the space it's gonna look all they're
gonna be touching right and that doesn't
look very good and it used to be up
until es6 which is the 2015 edition of
javascript every year the Ekman script
foundation which runs javascript adds
new updates to the language that we
would have to do something like that now
in in as of 2015 which was three years
ago
it has browsers for throughout the
throughout the world so you don't have
to worry about it not working in any
language we can use what's called string
and full string interpolation you'll
notice these backtick icons
if you're having the issue following
finding them on your keyboard it's that
to the left of the one what does this
gun allow us to do is essentially throw
in our variables with this dollar sign
curly brace opening curly brace closing
brace then we can put first name and
then we could just put space and then
another insert our variable here
last name and we can then add have it
print out nice and clean so when you're
trying to concatenate or add strings
together you might want to consider
using the curly braces alright now let's
go and give some methods that you're
going to be using with strings so what
is a method a method is a function what
is a function a function is a set of
instructions it's essentially how we are
gonna store our code and we'll go into a
little bit more detail about that later
on but in our example here javascript
strings come with some methods that
allow them to do certain things for us
and a good example of that is let's say
we wanted to have this print out will
have this long long length here we can
call this property dot length just to
get an idea here you'll see we have 24
spaces which is a lot right so each one
of these is a single space and we've
added a bunch and we had some more on
here it's gonna be up to 32 so that's
one string property that is going to
exist on every string another thing to
keep in mind is that maybe we want to
not have all this empty space on the end
what we can use is called the trim
property we're go ahead and drop this
down and you'll see dot trim and this is
going to remove all the empty space on
the end of the string and at the start
of the string and so when we save it
it's going to trim it and then you'll
see that our 32 length and we added more
on it's going to be just 12 right you
know Dylan Israel and then that plus one
empty character all right let's showcase
a few other methods about strings now
there's over 20 methods for pretty much
any data type and strings I think has
even more than that so we're just going
to touch on a few of these let's let's
start by cleaning this up
we don't we already showcase what trim
is we can go ahead and clean this up and
we showcase its length
we'll get the total amount of characters
that are in there so there's the two
upper case so you want to change the
whole world whole word to be to upper
case you'll see it's out there and as
you might have guessed there's also two
lower case they've that you'll see
everything's now lower case and there's
also split
so what splits going to do is this is
going to take in a parameter which
essentially means hey we want to a value
that's going to be used in this method
and by default if we pass so we're gonna
pass it in a single parameter you'll see
here I'm passing in an empty space one
empty space and what's that's going to
do it's just going to take this string
and then it's going to break up the
string based on all the empty spaces and
so you'll see we only have one empty
space so what we're going to get when we
save this is an array which is a which
is another data type we're gonna dive
into a little bit more that is going to
break our strings out into an array of
strings essentially going to find every
value in which there is a gap in here
and if we wanted to do it on every
character all we would do is pass in an
empty character and then you'll see
we'll get our entire string broken out
and even our empty character in that so
those are just a few of the more popular
if you will and widely use string
methods let's go ahead and talk a little
bit about numbers next
all right we're at our first challenge
here for the strings and what we're what
the objective here is we have our first
name and we have our last name what we
want to do is we want to concatenate a
value with full that called full name
that is then going to be printed out
you'll see right now full name is not
defined so let's go ahead and pause the
video real quick and see if you can fix
this to work come work well with your
first name and last and I spaced out
alright so hopefully you're able to do
this if not don't sweat it you're just
getting started so we're gonna define a
constable here because we're not going
to modify full name in reality we could
have done the same for first name and
last name as well if we want it to be
stay clear about it so there's two
different ways we can go about it we're
gonna do the first name plus the empty
space plus last name and this would work
just fine as well this would be
considered bad convention now that we
have that we have our standards and es6
as i mentioned earlier
so instead hopefully what you did was
use the back picks a dollar sign you
passed it in first name space last name
to get going here and that should have
worked for you just fine and of course
the semicolon at the end
all right so let's dive into numbers so
let's let's create a variable here
called example and we're set equal to 7
all right and then we just want to
console.log our example value out well 7
so this is a number it's pretty much
exactly how you'd expect it now if
you're more familiar with object
oriented languages one of the things
that may be a little bit different is
other languages have multiple number
types javascript does not JavaScript has
one number type and that is number so if
we created seven point seven seven
repeating that it's still a number and
we can check it again just with the type
of keyword and you'll see it's gonna
print out a number all right let's go
you have an example of parse int so
right now this is a floating-point
number right there's decimal places but
let's say that we only wanted to get the
integer value we'd use the park's int
function and just wrap it like so and
now we're just gonna get the whole
number seven which is nice right so
sometimes we may not want to you'll
notice it doesn't do any rounding or
anything like that all it's getting is
the integer here now sometimes you may
want to get the floating-point number
which is we can do with parsefloat just
as easily because we may not want to
drop that value want the whole value so
that's one way we can use it you'll also
notice that we can eat this out of a
string of ID number like so and save
that and you'll see we'll actually get
the number value from it so we can parse
and float from a string as well as parse
that int from a string of five number as
well now let's say that we wanted to
return a certain amount of decimal
places for our number that we have here
what we could do is it's going to get
rid of this percent we can use the to
fix which will return it and this is not
only just make dot to fix
let's say we want to do it five decimal
places like so you'll actually see it's
going to add zeros on there so it's
going to go seven point seven seven and
add these three zeros because that
doesn't exist but maybe we just want it
to the
one place right and you'll see it's
actually gonna round it up to seven
point eight so that's one way that we
can you know handle add additional
decimal places or set rather set a
certain amount of additional decimal
decimals while working with numbers
all right welcome to challenge number
two you'll see we have our the numbers
challenge rather you see we have four
values set up period one using partial
with a string with some numbers in it
one using parsefloat with a string with
some numbers in it and then we have a
number with two fix if you thought that
perhaps we could only call these methods
on variables that's not true we can
actually just put in the value directly
like so and then we have to fix on 200
with two so let's see if you guys can
guess what these values are actually
gonna output all right so at first you
may have thought that this percent was
kind of weird and you're right so when
we actually go ahead and put out example
one will comment these out like so and
save it you're gonna see that it's gonna
get null okay that makes sense this
isn't really a string but what do you
think is going to happen when we do the
same thing for parsefloat here well you
may be surprised with the results and
this is one of those things I was
mentioning earlier where people are
guessing well that's kind of wonky
you'll notice it actually pulls the 44
so whenever you parse it in or parse the
float and we'll go ahead and delete this
hello from this you'll notice it will
actually pull it out so if your string
starts with a number it will find it and
then pull it out this is probably not
something you ever want to do bad
convention but there's something worth
noting and then we have our number here
and I went to fix what do you think it's
gonna be should be 55 right so we're
gonna pass in example 3 save it like so
55 very nice and then finally we're
gonna call to fix on example 4 and
continue on great you may be wondering
why these are different colors what do
you think the types of all these are
let's go ahead and continue with part
two of this challenge
so if trying to figure out what each one
of these console.log types are all right
hopefully at a moment to think about it
so this first one is going to be a
number because we're actually pulling
out a number from it same thing with
this second one even though we're
pulling it out of the string number now
this to fix the to fix number property
what do you think that's going to be to
be
drink it actually converts it to a
string when it when it rounds it up or
drops or adds those values on a same
thing here so just a little wonkiness in
JavaScript worth mentioning
so up next we're gonna be talking about
boolean values so let's create a
variable here called example 1 and we're
set to true this is a true value there
is also a false value and as crazy as it
sounds that's pretty much it for boolean
x' really boolean czar a true or false
value you can kind of think of it as a
quarter there's a heads and there's a
tails it's a boolean czar true or false
it either has to be one or the other
where things get a little tricky with
billions are when we start dealing with
truth ii values and falsity values now
one thing i did want to mention is that
we have this boolean function here
that's going to evaluate if something is
a true or false value so you'll see here
if we save it it's gonna print out false
right because it is a false boolean and
it's gonna print out true because it is
a true boolean now if we pass in a
number what do you think it's gonna put
print out well it's gonna print out a
true because this is a value that is a
truth devalue and in that in our
challenge we're going to be talking a
little bit about that
all right we have eight examples here of
truthy and falsy values and what I want
you to do is just sort of make a mental
note or maybe comment below a line of
code or on piece of paper what you think
these outputs are going to be which ones
are going to be truthy which ones are
going to be false
let's start with the example one here we
already showcased this earlier that
false the boolean value of false is a
false e value and likewise with example
two
the true value here is a true value as
well okay what is null this is going to
be my only introduction to null in this
course it's not something I think we
really need to cover too much in detail
but no is really a referent of value
that we are referencing that essentially
says a developer plans on setting this
value later on and we're giving null as
a placeholder as an empty false e value
as you might see here as well and then
there's undefined which typically means
that this is also a false true value but
that usually means that either this
variable wasn't defined a lot of times
you'll see that okay if we can actually
assign undefined this way as well which
also be a false value but undefined
usually just means that there's a
variable or a property that doesn't
exist that you're trying to reference
it's usually a bug in your code when you
see an undefined so this is string this
empty character here what do you think
that's gonna be you might be surprised
to find out that's also a false e value
however what do you think if we put a
space there well that's gonna be it's
gonna be a truth eval you so empty empty
strings like that are false e values and
then we have this other value here na n
what is that stanford not a number
you're gonna get not a number when you
try to parse a string or something like
that where it's not going to return a
value properly or you know you're gonna
check there's there's some not a number
methods that we can check out to say hey
is this not a number but this is a
essentially value type just to tell you
that's not number and that's a false e
value as well and then we have negative
five and you're saying negative five I
wonder our negative numbers falsity or
truth values well negative numbers are
truth
values as well as positive numbers the
only false e value when it comes to
numbers is zero so be careful when
you're getting started with that so
that's some of a little bit more walking
this when it comes to the truth of your
false values in JavaScript
so next up is a race well whenever
you're trying to deal with multiple
values you're probably going to need to
deal with in a race so how do you
instantiate it all right have you said
that well you just use these square
brackets this is essentially our
container and then we can have multiple
things in here like so and then we can
have access to them later on but
essentially it's a list of items that
you're going to be using in your code
now remember earlier when we were
checking the length of the string we can
do the same thing with our example one
so with our array rather so let's go
ahead and print this out and we're gonna
call dot length on it and this is gonna
give us the length of array now one
thing to keep in mind when working with
the race so you'll see 0 1 a 1 2 3 the
length of this is 3 but say we wanted to
let's go ahead and change this to a 7
say we wanted to get this first value a
race start on the zero index and so
you're gonna see 0 that's 5 and then 1
that's 7 and then 2 that's gonna be 6
when you think 3 is going to return well
let's go returning all this doesn't
exist
NOLA undefined so something keep in mind
when working with a race is that they do
start on 0 and the length is always
going to be one greater than the last
index value now we're gonna be talking
about a few of the more common methods
when it comes to arrays but one thing to
keep in mind is there's about 20 or 25
methods with arrays that you're gonna
need to know inside and out and we're
only going to touch on about 3 or 4 just
to give you an idea of a few of them but
you're gonna probably need to review all
of these and perhaps in a set in a
separate course we can deep dive into
every single single function I have a
udemy course that does exactly that but
and say we want to add a value here to
example 1 we use the push method and
let's so go ahead and and push the
number 8 on there and we'll change this
to console.log what we want to put out
you'll see now we're gonna add that last
value we use push to add multiple values
so there 8 9 10
save that
BAM so it's gonna add all them but let's
say we want to remove the last value we
can use the pop method here it's gonna
remove the last value now one thing
that's so that's that's one way to add
and and add and remove the last values
in other ways of adding the beginning
values and adding and certain index
value we're not gonna worry about that
too much one more thing I want to show
you is how to override values so
remember earlier we were like oh well we
can target values to print out but let's
say we want to reset the value on that
index zero we do and we'll just put one
in there and you'll notice that we're
gonna overwrite what comes up on that
value and say we want to iterate through
the entire array like so we do that with
a for each statement and then the
element is going to be the current index
value or iterating on so in our case
it's going to be 1 then 7 then 6 then 8
and we just instead all we want to do is
console.log the element out here go
ahead and save it and what we're gonna
get is essentially 1 7 6 8 9 and then
the final rake because it's going to
iterate through each element in our
array
all right in our array challenge you'll
see we have a value here in rate value
so you'll notice that there's different
data types in here we have a string we
have a number and we have a truth a
value this is something that you can do
in JavaScript as well so we have a new
value here example 2 new variable and we
are sending it equal to example 1 and
then we are pushing 11 to example 2 now
my question for this challenge is what
do you think the value of example 1 is
going to be and what do you think the
value of example 2 is now it may
surprise you to find out that the values
are going to be identical you're going
to see that if I spell console dot log
right you're gonna see that we have
example 1 with the 11 as well as example
2 why is that why is that even though we
only pushed 11 on to example 2 that's
still getting exam passed you example 1
the reason for that is that when you're
dealing with arrays and objects you're
passing by reference what that basically
means is example 2 is setting a
reference or referring to example 1 it's
not actually creating a new array so
when you push the example 2 you're
actually pushing to example 1 and how
can we how can we create a new array but
still have these values in it well a
couple of different ways we can use the
spread operator which is going to dot
dot dot going to unwrap these values in
a new array like so and so this is gonna
this three dots is some es6 is going to
take all these values and essentially
push them through this new ring you'll
see that's going to create a brand new
array so it's not passing by reference
anymore another way that you can do this
is using the map functionality with is
which is an array method that creates a
brand new array like so and this is
going to be an element remember the
element really just refers to the
current index value we're iterating over
and we can return that element it's just
going to create a new array this is
going to be identical to the spread
operator I'd probably recommend doing
the sprite operator because it's less
code so just keep that in mind is that
when you're dealing with objects and
arrays
you are passing by references and
sometimes you may not want to do that
probably most the time and then you're
gonna actually want to create a new
array so that you can change the values
without affecting the original array
so objects much like arrays are probably
the two most important items that you
need to be intimately familiar with
objects are defined by these curly
braces like so and they can take in what
are called properties so remember how we
had our first name we can do it like
this and we'll put in Dylan and then we
can have another property and that can
be last name and that will be Israel
you'll see when we print it out it's
gonna print out this entire object but
we don't you know most of time when
we're displaying it for the user we
don't want the entire object we just
want the first name so we can use the
adult property and then we can get the
value that we want and this will
actually give us the first name property
so example one dot first name and we can
chain these downward as well and let's
say we do something like address and we
want to do city and we'll do Austin and
then we'll do state Texas so we have
this object here and excuse me and these
are strings right so they need to be
wrapped in quotes to develop that their
string and we could continue downwards
so we have address and then we do dot
city and then we'll get Austin now when
dealing with objects you can not just
use strings you also do like age for
instance on here I'm 30 you can do a
raise so how many cats do I have I
happen to have three one name is Milo
and then another is Tito and then
another its Achilles and I apologize I
don't know how to spell my cat's name
but you can use multiple data types with
many objects as well and you can also
reset the values in our object so let's
say we want to say you know it's my
birthday and we wanted to reset age for
instance time now 31 we could do that
and then we would target it if we wanted
to print it out to confirm you'll see we
now get 31
all right so some of the methods you
want to know about objects are objects
so I don't know if I made this clear
earlier or not but this property name
yeah will also be referred to as a key
and then its value here will be the
value so one would say we wanted to get
all the keys from our object we do that
with object the object type got keys and
then just wrap this like so and you'll
see when we print it out it's gonna
print out all our cubes notice how it
doesn't print out the nested keys as
well it's only gonna do it on the level
that you're doing that but let's say we
want all the values we do that as well
and we'd get our values had done Israel
we're gonna get a you know the object
here which is city and state 31 and then
our array of values sometimes you may
want to check if a property or a key
exists on our object one way that you
can do that is to say example one dot
has own property and then in there we're
gonna pass in a string value and this is
going to be the key that we're checking
for and that's gonna be first name
you'll notice it's true if we put first
name to return false that that key does
not exist in our object
now if you remember earlier when I said
that a race passed by reference so do
objects so what do you think when we
create this example one and then we set
example two equal to example one you'll
notice that we're actually assigning a
value to a property that doesn't exist
what do you think is gonna happen in our
object here well your first guess might
have been that this isn't even gonna
work but that would be mistaken example
two here is definitely going to add the
last name property on there now where
there might be an issue is say well and
do last name and then we do mother's
last name or something like that that
wouldn't work and the reason for that is
that last name it's not defined as an
object but example two is which is why
we can assign B last name property
directly to it and it works just fine
but you might have already guessed as I
told you earlier this will pass by
reference as well and so when we're
setting example two two example one
we're gonna go ahead and have these
values that are gonna get added to
example one as well so keep that in mind
when you're creating objects that you're
gonna need to instantiate a new object
and you're gonna need to pass in the
values directly instead of actually
having to go and and set and it's gonna
pass by reference so it may overwrite
your original object now how might we
create that object that class you know
typically the easiest way is using the
object method and when you're working in
classes we're not going to dive into
classes in this introduction course but
you might have a class that you would
create a new instance of but how do you
do it with objects well object has the
object prototype has this assign
property or method excuse me method oh
oh sorry a little bit of a issue here
and it's going to take in two properties
first what you want to assign it to
which in our case is an empty object and
second
what it is that we're going to assign it
to so you'll see here when we call
object of sign it's going to create a
brand new object which is I'm going to
go ahead and put the example one values
into example two and thus when we assign
a new property to example two it's not
going to pass by reference to example
one because here we're instantiating a
new object
so let's come back to working with
numbers again so we're gonna be talking
a little bit about the arithmetic
operators that are available in
JavaScript so right here we have our
example five we can add as you might
imagine and then we'll get ten we can
subtract like four and then we'll get
six we can of course times by four which
would be 16 my censoring at negative six
like so and you'll notice we don't have
to group these together
javascript is intelligent enough to know
the order of operations of math by
default and then we come of course
divide this by 4 so this is going to be
16 divided by 4 would be 4 10 minus 4 is
gonna return 6 so we have all the
standard math functionality when we're
dealing with our arithmetic operators
all right so hopefully those math
operators here were a little bit of
introduction or repetitive and you're
like out man I know how to plus and
minus excellent so let's hit you with
something that you may not be familiar
with
that's the modulo operator or modulus
operator so you see this percent sign
this is gonna return 0 why is that well
modulo returns remainders of numbers so
when we modulo 5 by 5 it divides evenly
and there's no remainder what you think
happens when we modulo by 6
well it's going to return the whole
number because it doesn't ever evenly
divide but if we modulo by 4 it's gonna
return 1 modulo by 3 gonna return 2
modulo by 2 it's gonna return 1 right
because it goes to 4 and then there's a
1 remainder so that's the modulo
operator
let's talk a little bit about relational
operators we have our two numbers here
10 and 15 and so this is a sort of
relation to the math operators we don't
really dive into it but relational
operators will compare two items and
then return a boolean value of a true or
false value so when we take example 1
which is 10 and we say greater than
greater than or equal to example 2 what
you're gonna expect it to return is
false right because 10 is not greater
than or equal to hover if this was 15 it
equals it so it is greater than or equal
to of course have less than or equal to
as well which will evaluate the true as
10 is indeed less than or equal to 15
now the other relational operators are
are these values equal are these double
equals is 15 equal to 10 that's false
right it's not but if we change example
2 to 10 that's true and if we use triple
equals that's true as well and we're
gonna talk in the challenge about what
the difference between the double equals
and the triple equals is and and why
that's really important so here you'll
see that we are comparing the values so
let's say we want to see if they're not
equal how can we do that well we can use
this exclamation point and equal sign to
be false right you guess 10 is equal to
10 thus that's false now is 10 not equal
to 12 that is true so it's going to
return true and then vice versa with
this extra equals here to return true as
well before we move on to the challenge
I want to actually talk about this
double equals and triple equals and what
that basically means remember earlier
when we were console logging out the
data type so in our example here we're
going to log out example the type of
example 1 and the type of example 2
which is going to return a number and
number right now so javascript is a
dynamically typed language what that
means is in JavaScript we have no
problem taking this very
here which has a type of number and
going head and setting it to a boolean
for instance that's something that we
can do in JavaScript all day it's it's
not a big deal
now most languages are statically typed
so what that means is that if I wanted
to have a number here I'd probably have
to create and reset it assigned to a
boolean I would have to have some
additional logic or a new variable or
something like that but we have console
so each one these are numbers and when
we want to do the comparison there is a
strictly equals comparison that compares
the value and type and then there is a a
sort of less strict comparison that
compares only the value so that's the
real difference here when we do this
double equals all we're checking is that
the values are the same so example one
is equal to example two it's going to
return false right but let's say we
change this to the number 10 the number
10 or excuse me the value 10 is equal to
the value 10 is double equals that's a
true statement however if we change this
to a string and the Loosli equals here
it's still going to be true even though
that this is a number 10 and and a a
string 10 because all it cares about is
the value however if we use the strictly
equals and we take example one as triple
equals to example two what it's going to
check is not only that 10 is equal to 10
but also what is the data type is number
equal to string in that case it's not
which is why it's going to return false
and the double equals on the not
remember the bang this and this it's the
same same there as well as checking the
type and the value
all right let's get a little practice in
with the triple equals and the not
equals so in our four examples here
let's think a little bit about what is
it that we're checking and we're
checking are these values equal are
these values equal are these values not
equal and are these values not equal
let's think about it for a second and
then dive into it alright so in our
first example it's going to console the
log out example one so remember with the
strictly equals this is checking type in
value they both their numbers and they
both have the value of five so we're
going to expect that to be true now
example two is five
equal equal to string five now the
Loosli equals is just checking the type
so it's a value five equal to the other
value five and that is indeed true
unless we're going to expect that to be
true and let's go move on to the knot as
well so in example three here is the
value six not equals to the value six
and that's gonna return what do you
think it's fair return false because it
is actually a true statement six number
is equal to six string because we're
doing a loosely comparison in vice versa
when we do console.log example four
that's going to return true because the
console that low is not a thing so
console dot log true because the string
value seven is unequal to the number
value seven and thus that returns true
all right so sometimes we may just want
to increment a number by one a lot of
times what we're doing is for loops or
we're dealing with iteration as well as
subtract by one so how might we do that
well at at first glance you may do
something like this where you said
example 1 is equal to example 1 plus 1
right and then you'd see oh of course it
go up by two but this is such a common
thing that JavaScript has built in a
very easy way to increase by one by
throwing this plus plus on our variable
and you'll see now we still get the same
result if we were to call it again we're
gonna get we're gonna get three because
we've now added one then we've add
another one to get three it also has a
easy way to subtract and we can do that
with - - and so our one minus one will
become zero but let's say that we don't
want to add or subtract by one how might
we do that well pretty straightforward
so we take example one and we're gonna
use this plus equals and then we're
gonna say five and this is gonna add 5
to it 6 this is exactly the same thing
again as us doing example 1 is equal to
example 1 plus 5 similar to how we did
plus plus except now it's plus equals
now this isn't only relevant to adding
or subtracting subtraction would work as
well you'll see we'll get 4 but also we
can multiply 1 times 5 is 5 we can
divide so we'll get point 2 we can even
do our modulus operator that we showcase
earlier where modulo when u modulo by a
number of greater than the number is
gonna return the whole number so if we
did something like 10 for instance scan
return 0 if we did 13 it have a
remainder of 3 so that's a couple ways
that we can increment decrement in
JavaScript
all right and their increment and
decrement challenge we're gonna hit you
with something you really haven't been
exposed to one of the stranger parts so
you'll see here we have example1
example2 you both equal to five and then
you're seeing here we're adding one to
example five million we get we didn't
talk about plus plus on the front of a
variable what do you think the
difference between these two might be
there is a difference it's subtle but
there is a difference what do you think
it might be all right so let's go ahead
and uncomment these lines of code here
and see what the values are you can see
it's six and six you're saying you know
doing this is the you know want two ways
to do the same thing and at first glance
it may appear that way but in reality
not so let's instead of console logging
the value out here put our example plus
plus as the value in our console logs
and see what happens this is going to be
a plus example two so what do you what
are you expecting these values to be
you're saying what look probably gonna
be six and six you'd be wrong so you see
it's five and six the reason for that is
when we do the plus plus on the end it's
going to add this value after this line
of code if you do it on the beginning
it's essentially gonna do it within the
line of code now he depends is there you
know there's very few instances where
I've ever found need to have to do the
plus plus on the beginning typically
you'll see most lines of code will just
have this as its own line of code but if
you wanted to add it the iteration on
the exact line of code you'd have to
throw it on the beginning of your
variable so that's one difference that
you may never known and this this will
be the same with - - as well
let's go ahead and talk a little bit
about control flow using if else--if and
and else and what they are so sometimes
you only want your code to run for
certain reasons so in our if statement
like so we can say we can pass an
example which is v we're saying if this
is equal equal to five meaning does this
evaluate to true go ahead and
console.log we want to put this will put
true statement or we'll just put runs so
you'll see when we run this it's run
because it is equal to this however if
we were to say that this is equal to six
this wouldn't run right we get no
printout and so our code nested within
our curly braces here never actually
runs in our if statement so this if
statement essentially is a gatekeeper
that evaluates this logic here to tell
us if something is true or not now what
is else--if else--if
is a statement that runs only if this
statement here if this if statement
failed so you have to have an if for
there to be an else if so this else if
is directly court connected to this if
statement so if this fails we're gonna
run another if statement here that's
going to say uh in our case we'll just
put true that's gonna run and and it
will just put console dot log else if
and you'll see now this is going to
print out else if because this failed
and then checks is this true it is
unless it prints so if we change this
back to five and evaluate it you'll see
it's now printing out run so it's not
printing out the else if because this
already evaluated is true and thus it
never runs our else--if because again it
only runs if the F fails so what is else
else is the default value so if the F
fails if the ELSA fails and there's no
true values between between them we're
gonna go ahead and print the console dot
law or we're gonna go ahead and run our
code in our else statement which in our
case we're just going to print out
you'll see runs runs ok so if we changes
the six that's going to fail so this
fails and that runs ok cool itself so if
oh it is true
so print elsif but what if this was
false it's gonna finally get all the way
down to the cells because this fails
then this fails and then we finally hit
our else all right one other thing worth
mentioning that we haven't talked about
is and and or so so far we've only been
evaluating statements one statement at
time what if we wanted to evaluate two
statements to make sure both of them
weren't sure not only is example in our
case equal equal to five and we'll just
say true is equal equal to true so what
this and statement this double ampersand
here saying is hey when we run our code
check that not only is this true but and
this is true as well which is why this
runs and vice versa if we change this so
that example is equal to go to six which
it's not it's gonna fail and this is
false so it's gonna hit our else
statement even though this is true but
let's say we wanted to have it where if
either one of these conditions are true
run our code we would use an or
statement like so which is these two
pipes and then we've run our code so
it's example equal to six no that's
false but true is in fact equal to true
and thus this runs now if false was
equal to true it's gonna fail right
because this is false there this
statement here is false in this
statement and here is false so that's
and an or it allows us to concatenate
essentially our conditions and check
multiple conditions again or is saying
hey if either one and then and would be
you know if both are true and we can do
this as many times as we need in our
code
all right let's see if you can guess the
true or false values using our an and or
operators we have three of them take a
second take a look and then we'll go
piece by piece all right hopefully you
took a second take a look let's take a
look at this first one we have a triple
equals comparison on ten being equal to
ten and five is less than four so we're
going to evaluate these two statements
this is true and this is false thus it
should return false and hopefully that
was what you got here
false very nice let's look at a very
similar statement with the only change
in the logic here being an or statement
well on the left hand side we have a
true statement on the right hand side we
have a false statement but because we're
using an or operator because one of them
is true this is going to return true
very nice so last but not least a little
bit more of a complex one we did we
didn't I said earlier that you can
increase the complexity of this very
quickly but you'll see here that we are
essentially wrapping this statement here
and then doing an and to compare this
side so it may look like there's three
comparisons but but really are more than
two comparisons but there's just this or
and there's this and so in here we're
saying is five less than or equal to
five
or excuse me greater than equals five
that's a true statement or is 4 greater
than four that's a false statement but
because one of these is true which is
this statement this whole block here
evaluates the true and then we evaluate
this side it's 3 plus 2 equal to 5 it is
and thus we return true as well so you
can see how this can get a little bit
crazy relatively quickly but I think
that some good practice and if you're
interested in practicing this you just
want to get it down just Google control
flow practice on practice JavaScript
online you'll come across a bunch of
like you know 20 30 questions of things
like this at a time that you can
practice with
so let's talk about switch statements
really quickly switch statements are
gonna feel very similar to an if-else
if-else statement because it is again
some control flow on your code but the
difference with the switch statement is
say we're checking a finite amount of
answers and you want to know you only
want to run some code for three or four
answers and then you have a default to
assume is really a different way of
writing if-else if-else statement let's
go ahead and give an example say we are
taking a test and we answer a four-hour
test so our student answer in our switch
statement we're going to have this value
here and we're gonna pass in a student
answer and what that is to say hey check
our answer for each one of these cases
and then run some code so in a tech a
case follows by a value so we have you
know case a and then in in right below
it we'll have something that says
something like you know we'll console
dot log wrong and then we have to break
out of the switch name and this break is
very important because if you don't
break out of it basically this code is
gonna run if our student answer here is
a but if we don't break out of it when
we have another case like B it's gonna
continue to it's gonna continue checking
your code to make sure that it's right
and we'll just put console dot log B is
wrong
just forsake a is wrong and then we'll
say C is the answer and then again for
our case here we need to break out of
the logic otherwise we're gonna have
some issues with it checking multiple
answers when really the switch statement
is designed to only it should only go
for the correct answer and C and we're
going to put will just call us alot log
C is correct period and then we want to
break out of here so let's actually run
our code like so and save it and you'll
see we'll get a is wrong so our answer a
here it's wrong if we change this to be
we're going it B is wrong and if we
change it to see we're gonna get see
it's correct very nice so what happens
we put this to be a nothing rinse none
of these is correct but maybe we want a
default answer so if a value comes in
well there's this default keyword here
which is essentially our else where if
all the other answers fail go ahead and
console B is wrong as well because
there's only four answers or but not a
real answer and you'll see we get not a
real answer here because it is an A it
isn't B it isn't C and then we get not a
real answer because this is a default
value you'll notice how I don't break
from here the break here is so that no
additional things are ran you don't
really need a break on default it's I
couldn't tell you if it's clean
convention or not but there's no reason
to do it unless code is better typically
but that's a switch statement you pass
in a value you then check a case to see
if it matches any and then you also have
the default here just make sure you
break otherwise you might run into a lot
of errors down the road where you know
has multiple correct answers or your
logics not going to work properly
now let's say that we wanted to iterate
through up to the numbers 0 to 5 to add
those values to total how might we do
that well for loop would be an excellent
way of doing that and when you create
one by first instantiate a variable
essentially a counter variable usually
initialized by I for iteration we're
gonna started off at 0 and then this
statement here I is less than 5
this essentially will continue to run
our for loop until this statement no
longer is true and then we're gonna
increase number the I plus plus by 1
every iteration and so if we were to
console dot log out I right now what
we're gonna see here the number is 0 1 2
3 4 and then I is not less than 4 I when
it's 5 is not less than 5 thus it breaks
the for loop doesn't run the logic
inside here and then exits out so how
might we now modify our code to add the
values of I to total what we can do that
by just doing total plus equals 2 I now
let's let's go ahead and console dot log
out the values of total which we know
are those index values so when we
console dot log out total you'll see
that is now added all of our values to
equal 10 so 0 plus 1 is 1 plus 2 is 3
plus 3 is 6 plus 4 is 10 and we get our
value there now this is of a for loop
where we're gonna actually know how many
iterations it's going to be 5 but how
might we iterate through an array when
we don't know how many values did it
rate through so let's create an array
here and we'll just call this a number a
and this is gonna be equal to we'll just
throw in some numbers of 10 10 20 30 40
50 60 70 and 80 so we could in theory
say you know go ahead and put less than
8 but that's not good practice that's
not what you want to do with the race
because maybe we add a value to this
later on so how might we make this a bit
more dynamic well we can set our our
right side here to no more
a length remember that dot length
property which is going to have this run
for as many iterations that are in our
in our array for the length of the array
but instead of actually adding the total
value of just being the index value we
want the values out of the no more rate
how might we do that well remember the
index values are accessed with numbers
right so if we want to just add index
zero we've put that in there or index
one or index 2 but we want it to be on
the con for every value so every
iteration our I gets updated and thus
you'll see when we console dot log out
that value here right above total no
more a I it's gonna hit the zero and
then one and ten and you'll see that we
get all our values in the console so
we're already adding all those values
and now this we've been able to access
them with our I variable here and so so
at the end we get a very large 360
number because we've added all the
values in our number right and vice
first if we added 90 on here you'll see
that it will run and we don't have to
refactor any of our code
so let's say we want to repeat our code
but we don't know there's not a finite
amount of answers so we can't use a
switch case we don't know what the
length of the array is gonna be or we
don't know how many iterations to run we
just want it to run until a value is
true so a while loop might be what
you're looking to do here while loops
are another way to run iterations of our
code and so what a while loop does is it
runs until some sort of value here is
false in our case we'll just let's go
ahead and say count is greater than 20
you know this could be anything in here
and in our while loop we're gonna go
ahead and and add we're gonna say uh you
know we're gonna do some logic and then
maybe at the animal cell count plus plus
now the the reason that this may seem
very similar and in its current setup it
is and then at the end we'll go ahead
and complement log count if we want to
and so this never runs as you notice
here because count is never greater than
20 because this is false statement but
let's go ahead and change it so less
than it's gonna run 20 times and you
could do this in a for loop that's true
but you can do some things with this
where we're let's let's forget about
numbers for a second maybe we want to
have a local value where we're just you
know where we're gonna run this while
it's true and in here we're gonna put
true but we need to make sure now that
we've put hard-coded a true value in
here that we are going to break out of
this so what we can do is if we want to
if if count is less than 20 go ahead and
greater than or equal to 20 what we want
to do is we're gonna start off first off
by adding and then you'd have an
additional logic then you would say
you'd say something like break so this
will break us out of our for loop so
when it's 20 we're gonna exit out of our
for loop here as well so while loops are
a way to run your logic run your code
for a set amount of time when you don't
know how many times that's going to be
now there's also do-while loops at which
are a little bit different than then
while loops the main difference between
a while loop and a do-while loop is a
do-while loop will run at least once
remember when we set this to false
earlier and this is a false statement
count never got touched and never ran
this code not even once - to see -
update count but if we had a do-while
loop it would do it so let's go ahead
and convert this while loop to a
do-while loop it's pretty straight
forward so we're gonna do with these
closing braces these curly braces and
basically all our logic here is gonna be
in our do-while loop and we're gonna
remove the curly braces on the wall'
loop and just have wall after-the-fact
like so now you'll see when we save our
code here count is actually going to be
equal to 1 even though our while loop is
false so it's gonna run this one
iteration count is still not greater
than or equal to 20 so we don't break
out of the do-while loop but the actual
while statement itself is false we only
run at the one time because it's a
do-while loop so just something keep in
mind I it's very rare that I use a while
loop or do a loop but is worth
mentioning for those times where you
don't have any way of knowing how many
iterations and you're basically checking
a value until you get a right value to
break you out of it and that could be
anything from more count is you know
equal equal to you know feeling or
something like that where you can't
check the the length right so you can do
check properties the the main thing to
keep in mind is that is that you are
going to be it's usually not used with
numbers but it's a for a set amount
iterations that you don't know you just
need to keep doing it
till you get the result you're looking
for but it is also a word of caution a
good way to create an infinite loop
which will crash your program and and
maybe stop it all together
all right last but not least functions
so we need to define a function what is
a function a function is a way of
storing our code so that we can call it
again and again and reuse it
part of being a software developer prior
to being any developer is writing
reusable code and it's a a part of
development that you're gonna have to
get comfortable with so let's go ahead
and define a function well write a
simple function called add in JavaScript
you just noted by the keyword the name
of the function and then these
parentheses and then we have our curly
braces for our logic so in our example
here if we just want a console table add
o and you'll see well save nothing
happens well we have to actually invoke
the function like so by just calling it
by its name curly braces or excuse me
parentheses and you'll see here we
actually print out add very nice and we
can do this time and time and time again
so you'll see we actually get add to
print out four times just the power of a
function is that we have the same item
being able to work with multiple be able
to be used multiple times now this isn't
a very impressive function so let's adds
let's actually add some logic to it so
this return word here what say we wanted
to return a value return in a function
will allow us to do that so let's return
five and you'll see nothing prints out
but we can go ahead and console dot log
three wrap these ads in a console dot
log will actually print out the value
that's being returned which is in our
case five and you'll see we get the five
like so so now we're returning a value
so this return keyword will return a
string return a number return a boolean
whatever it is that you need will return
it within the function now that's still
not very impressive we're not adding
anything and based off our name here a
function name you think something would
need to be at so functions can take in
what are called parameters in our case
we're gonna call this number one and the
way that
so this is our prime parameter and what
we're gonna pass into the actual
function call is an argument it's
basically the value for num1 so we're
gonna pass in let's pass in 10 here and
so in our case we're gonna still print
out 5 because we're not using them 1 but
let's say we return num1 we're now gonna
get 10 and if we did the same thing here
we can now put 15 and now put 20 and
we'd get it to return 10 15 and 20 still
not that impressive but you can add
multiple parameters in our case here
num2 or now we want to add these two
numbers together so what is no 1 plus
num2 so if we put 10 and then we add 6
and we take 15 and we add 7 and we take
20 and we had to what are we gonna get
we are now getting 16 22 and 22 which is
now we have a function add that will add
two numbers anytime we need and we've
created this reusable code so when we're
writing our when we're solving problems
typically you're gonna write it in a
function so that you can reuse it and
call it and not have to duplicate your
code that's really the point of
functions and how you use them
our first and foremost
so finishing the course is an amazing
thing taking on the task of learning a
new concept learning a new programming
language and I commend you for that now
might I ask on my behalf as well
screaming calm to go ahead and share the
course if you enjoyed it I think it
covers a lot of great introductory
topics to Java scripting can be a great
benefit now where do we go from here
because the in learning it's all about
practicing and retaining that
information right it may all make sense
as at that moment but we want to make
sure that it makes sense for the rest of
your life and you need to do that you
need to start practicing with it there
is a wonderful playlist on scramble
column called Jas algorithms it'll give
you the opportunity to take some of
these methods to dive a little bit
deeper with these data types and
understand them and actually use what we
discussed in here so I encourage you to
check that out and you can just go on
and go in search for Jas algorithms on
screen Metacom thank you so much for
watching the course in being a part of
it I hope you learned a lot and I wish
you the best of luck in your JavaScript
endeavors